who are the billionaires of the world
the richest women in the world how did
they get to be the richest women their
husbands what does the title say to you
like modern women prefer to be or more
ready to be mothers than wives what does
that say to you wife material need to be
someone is going to be good take care of
yourself of herself and the house I like
the whole idea of being like a woman to
a man like doing what you have to do for
a guy when you hear that title what
comes to your mind
it's not me
not much just it's there's pure baby
mums out there and not much weddings
going on that's what the first thing I
thought of I know it sounds bad but it's
not mad it's real but yeah that's what
it sounds like to me yeah
do you find it was it like kind of like
oh that's a bit like rude or did you
find it to be rude or
no
I don't think it was really just
different parts of life in it like okay
all right fair enough Wicked uh what
about you what do you think about the
title modern women prefer to me Mothers
than wives I think it depends on the
culture let's say the European women
would rather be a
a woman I think Americans and Brazilian
are going to be a mother priority became
the child became the first priority in
her life
as soon zero became a mother so it came
as the more responsibility that the men
normally have
so
it depends I would rather say like it's
not an option when you have a child
the whole society
you are the mother and then let's say if
you have a divorce and you are the one
walking away what a bad mother you are
so a lot of stigma in the society we
need to be the mother and the main
character of the child so do you think
don't you think men get bad stigma as
well when they walk away from their
children
not as much as women
women don't really have the opportunity
to walk away like that and women women
intrinsically on uh you know
instinctively don't want to walk away
from children whereas a man basically he
could like for instance a man could
impregnate all the women in this room
and basically walk away whereas you're
gonna be stuck with the embryo growing
inside you so again don't you think men
usually get a bad rep if they walk away
from their children not as much as a
woman I think like I would love to be a
father I would have ten thousand
children you'd love to be a father and
have ten thousand children what
if women naturally it's like you think
right we have this in natural intrinsic
like we want to be mothers right however
there's so many women killing their kids
nowadays I mean [__] there's so many
girls with their their womb may as well
be a graveyard honestly so on one hand
women want to be with their kids but I
feel like they only want their kids if
it's with the right guy yeah
they're also one of the first people
that are like um they're most likely to
kill their kid within the first like
year or so there's some stat that's like
the most likely person that is to kill a
child in the first like year to two
years of life it's the bomb yeah well
that would make sense because since
they're spending the most time with the
child and probably the child's I don't
know making them miserable or getting
them in there so like obviously that's
gonna be the number one culprit that
makes a lot of sense so the loneliest so
depressed after the the birth women is
facing a lot at the same time they need
to keep being wives they need to be
professional a mother a cleaner a cooker
so do you think it's hard okay do you
think do you think like on average or
typically women's lives are harder than
men's because you're saying all these
things yes we need to deal with the
period once in a month you guys have no
clue what is that so you think because
you have a period once a month that
makes your life harder than the typical
man out there I were giving a symphony
spend it just to prove you get three
days off from work because they could
prove the kind of pain you feel when you
have prepared or during the period and a
man will die if they had this pain
mentally men don't survive flu they
would never survive oh
man
you honestly think you honestly think
that women's lives are harder than men's
lives just because they have a period we
are born to be breeding to be the
carrier to be the the superhero in the
house like you need to be strong in and
he protects you who who traditionally
predict protects women we are made to be
the protectors we don't have no no no
listen who traditionally usually
protects women
it depends what we talk about in a war
let's say about like she said mans go to
the war but I wish we live in a world
that we don't have no you know I I I
listen I'm not being mean but you're
just not answering the question at all
who usually protects women
I mean if if I uh if I need protection
I'm not calling the local women's
shelter I'm calling a man so let's talk
about the Vikings when their husbands
were away doing everything the women
were they were they were staying there
were farmers but they also could defend
themselves it's always a point of view
it depends where you're from are you a
viking I can defend myself oh but I I I
had I came from a strong woman if he
attacked okay if he attacks any of us
okay yeah I bet he's scary honestly if
any of these guys in the room attacked
any of us we ain't doing [__] I'm sorry
I'm sorry I'm gonna just say this right
now if I call the police and they send
me a woman I am pissed I am pissed I
don't want a woman to protect me I want
a man to protect me why why on Earth
would I call the cops and they send me a
woman it's like I I'm stronger and
taller than most girls what are you
gonna do I I call the police for men I
guess my point on the Vikings is that
when there's no other option the the
example that you gave is that there was
no other option the Viking women when
their men weren't off at Sea they
wouldn't just like go handle the the
Skirmish they would call their husbands
or the men in the in the tribe but once
the men are missing then yeah sure
they've got to defend themselves if the
other Vikings came back they're stealing
your women like if another tribe came
I really do want to answer the question
that he said because I feel like men men
and women have really hard lives like I
feel like with men they're consistently
you're not really allowed to show your
emotions like go up to cry you're meant
to be a protector that there's things
there's levels to your like life that
you're meant to go towards and if you're
not doing those standards you're not
really seen as a man so it's kind of
hard in that sense and then with women
it's like oh you can't do this you can't
dress like that or like you think so
much you can't do this you can't do that
most of the things that they can't do a
lot of women don't want to do
when you really think about it a lot of
like for instance oh yeah uh oh is
there's discrimination people think that
women can't are not strong enough to go
and fight this or do these kind of
physical activities most of the time
other women don't want to do it they
don't want to I'm looking for me I'm a
traditional girl like I think I'm not
gonna say I'm not I'm not I'm not I'm
not going at you I'm not going at you
but I'm I'm rebottling that point of
like
um it's it my point is this that being a
man I don't think a lot of women
understand the gravity of being a man
they just don't that's why you start
talking about a woman's life's heart
because she has a period that's that's
okay monthly and I'm a man monthly too
do you understand the threat of violence
that men have to face every single day
do you understand that
yes do you understand that if you have a
boyfriend or a husband or whatever he
has to protect you so therefore his life
is at risk all the time because you
never know who's around that next corner
if you two are walking down the street
and someone attacks you or whatever or
violates or something like that he's
Batman not you
so you can think you're strong as you
are but you know that if if you have to
step in front of him to catch a bullet
for him you're not going to respect him
you're not gonna there's a that's
already destabilized that's not that's
not real life you know that and once I
was in a situation my ex-boyfriend I was
the one fighting with the guys were
trying to rob Us in Brazil and what was
he doing that's why she was crying and
where's he at yeah
you said God knows because you don't
care because you look to him like right
like I had to save you could you look at
him the same after be honest I was the
one saving him at the time so let's say
this kind of man you're talking about I
wish we have more this kind of man but
unfortunately the new generation are not
this kind of man protector and and like
she said it's okay I think we should
talk about mental health about this
stigmas we need to break for a better
future do you understand so so with that
being said do you understand that a
man's life is probably harder than that
the typical man's life is probably
harder than the typical woman's life do
you do you agree with that it depends we
still have a low salary we're still not
in there
politics we are not in charge and let's
say yeah because we suck at it yup yup
I'm gonna say it I'm gonna say it women
are worse in leadership roles than men
we're worse at it and if we are doing
the leader thing the and see us as men
honestly them kind of women find it hard
to find men have you ever had a female
boss did you enjoy it really most women
are not great bosses and so we deserve
less money
oh I don't know about that part I I
definitely do I agree with that do you
think if you do a worse job you deserve
less money
I work with both genders and most of the
time when you want something to be to be
talked U.S command when you need
something to get done you ask a woman we
are so much more much tasked than men
see that sounds nice and that's the
narrative we've pushed right that sounds
really nice however you know what they
did one time are they they did this in
an episode right they they threw some
women on an island and some men on an
island and said survive for a TV show
and survive here let's see who can
survive better right the women they the
men
put themselves in a hierarchy right and
they said you do this you do that you do
that they had like running water in the
first day the women couldn't get [__]
done they had to get saved in like two
days because they were literally about
to die women in general I'm not saying
they're on exceptions to this rule you
know we got we got my lady Oprah she got
a really cool talk show but in general
who are the billionaires of the world
the richest women in the world how did
they get to be the richest women they're
husbands their husbands we there are
things that we are naturally good at
we're good nurturers right we're I I I
personally think we do good talk shows
however however I just think in general
when it comes to Building Society men
they they Dominate and they do the jobs
that are more needed in society and
therefore if you do a better job you
deserve more money thank you
Dee would you agree that men pretty much
build Society just like Pro was saying
pretty much
let's start that a man need a woman to
come through this world
can we talk about dogs give birth dogs
give birth listen listen this is the
thing yeah like every time I ask you a
question you always go to Vikings or
Guardians of the Galaxy or something
like like I'll ask you a straight
question because if you ask me a
question I'll answer you I'm not going
to talk about what I ate yesterday you
get what I'm saying so do when you think
about Society yeah or just think about
civilization or whatever don't men
usually build everything more than
likely just men build everything
like for instance this building we're in
how many women do you think helped build
this building
how what about the roads what about the
cars I agreement what about the
protection
what about the fact that you can walk
about at night and feel somewhat safe to
walk about at night and travel like it's
because
the man excuse to build up stuff of
course we need to demand this but of
course we also need the women what I'm
trying to say like there is no gender we
survive without the other simple like
that you're trying to tell me who's more
important or but it's not it's not
really an important thing that's not
what I said I'll say that I feel like
she's feeling a little bit no no no it's
called a minute it's called minute but
like obviously you can think what you
think in it like but I do I actually I
do think men would be able to survive
without women if we take out
reproduction they would be able to build
societies and make Society run women I
just don't think can do that now you see
you see and again we see that in in the
experiment where they put the men on the
island and they put the women on the
island they said survive go right the
men could figure it out the women
couldn't so on a small scale we can
already see men can survive without
women do I think they would be as happy
no the men love the women they love the
women but from like a survival point of
view yeah I Will Survive I would say I
don't think it's a conversation though
because you have to reproduce to survive
so well you say you're gonna survive you
aren't going to survive but the the
question is is we're just in a
hypothetical situation so taking
reproduction out of it obviously for
human you know whatever but in this
initial situation if we just dumped if
the world was just men or the world was
just women for as long as it runs for
who would probably be more efficient at
survival well there's no question men
built the world they built the roads
they built the houses they build the
bridges they build things and women
build people so you need both that's the
whole point mom is that there's no thank
you in society to men like we often [__]
on men as a thank you for for building
for building the society that we're
allowed to live well I think that we
just pretend it isn't true and that's
the part that's that's the part I
disagree with you yeah but what I just
said is true but it's like even even
there's like there's always pushback
whenever we say that men do something
well it's always but what about women
yeah every time every time that's true
I'm looking back because women have
periods
but anyway
you need to prepare for don't kill
anyone because you get really close and
I know yeah that's true that's true and
that's that's true like the majority of
men face a lot of rejection in in life
as well
and he makes them feel like crap
but women don't think about that side of
things either women would literally die
from that yeah women like guys get
rejected on things that are even outside
of their control
and there's no ISM for that or that's
like come on man like you can't really
say all because it makes you feel you
had a period so it makes you feel what
about the guys that you ignore the guys
that in your friend zone that would love
to date you that you don't ever give
them a chance for about how they feel
men are not ready to get rejected that's
the issue when they feel that oh I mean
to you you need to say yes it doesn't
work like that they'd never ever accept
when you're not interested on that it's
something that hurts it's easy and it's
easy for you to say that because you
never have to live that life I do of
course we all get rejected what's no
once in a while you think to the same do
you think that you lived you experienced
the same level of rejection in dating
that the average man does no of course
not exactly so you don't you don't know
how he feels because you don't
experience that and you put and think
about this how many guys have you
approached in this year
um three three yeah three
[Laughter]
that's funny man
let me let me uh let me ask you on pills
Mom all right so
um what does the title what does the
title say to you like more than women
prefer to be or more ready to be mothers
than wives what does that say to you I
think it's a sad statement of society
because I think that the family unit
isn't important and moms aren't seeing
the need for the dad in the in in that
and so I think that's the prerequisite
to
to being a mom is the dad that comes
with it
okay all right awesome awesome Wicked
all right you lot make sure you hit the
like button man a lot of you are in here
and that is awesome make sure you are
doing your part being interactive and
all that good stuff we've got over 300
people watching already so get your
fingers working hit that like button
it's free all right also hitting the
Super Chat as well support what we're
doing over here because we are all we
got yeah guys stop being Cheapo send
some super chats King riches has been
working his ass
working his ass off machine business
machine TT 1000 business
he's been doing everything around here
you know what I really appreciate the
love that means I love it Samsung supers
all right man Paul told you so not do it
you know what I'm saying all right cool
next question yeah uh what makes a woman
wifey material
all right what makes a woman wifey
material in your opinion
it doesn't matter I was gonna get you no
matter where you sit
it's okay I'm really not like where we
can yeah we can talk about it together
um
oh can you come back to me let me let me
is it a hard question
it's the way I would have to wear it I
want to think about it properly like I
don't want to do something it's a hard
question yeah
cool what do you think well if material
needs to be someone is going to be good
take care of yourself of herself and the
house
someone's gonna be in charge and of
everything and be happy with that's a
wife material for sure
take care of the house and and what was
it everything everything that about the
relationship
organizing the holidays being that
person organizing the holidays yeah yeah
like Manchester
exactly that's life material
organizing holidays no I want to answer
I think of my mom oh
all right you can go first
okay you want me to go first or you want
to go first oh you can go first you sure
you sure no hold up hold up hold up hold
on have you thought of anything yet
because she's gonna go off what you like
say well have you thought of anything
yet
um yeah like okay cool let me see it
I feel like wife material is like
someone that's like your piece someone
that you can go to like that's always
got your back that will help you through
stuff that you can actually be your true
self with someone as a grinder that you
know wants to be able to hustle with you
you know I mean sees your vision and
goes with it as well like I said as I
said before I'm quite a traditional girl
like I want my man to call you yeah how
that momentum you know and I follow you
know I'll do my own thing I have my own
thing but I'm helping him be his best
hymn because when he's his best I'm even
better personally I know that sounds mad
but if his money's up and I've helped
him get there he's gonna treat me
because I helped him get there
you just like she said this week it's
your best start laughing like like but
all right okay cool if you could just
list it because like list it in bullet
points where you think wifey material
looks like just bullet points of what
you said
um
their peace
someone that cooks cleans you know that
stuff
I know it sounds bad no I don't it don't
sound much just like say what you're
thinking it yeah and makes them happy
obviously
good at communicating
just the simple stuff I feel like it's
simple yeah and then I mean some guys
who like the girls that don't go out and
party all the time
and dress appropriately
you know those are the minor ones okay
over to you guys can I go first mom go
ahead thank you okay so first off I
think if some things my mother taught me
all right so shout out Jen sorry Mom
sorry sorry I know you hate it when I do
that
okay so first of all I feel like a wife
material is someone that values family
the family has to come before her so a
lot of times like women are like oh I
need to leave to be happy I need to do
no no no the family comes before you
okay that's number one two you can't be
sleeping around the whole town I'm sorry
you know if you slept with the whole
football team you're probably not wife
material all right all right three young
you can't be too old all right we're not
trying to have yet 70 like if you're 60
you're looking for a husband 40 looking
for a husband where have you been the
last 20 years probably with the football
team you know what I mean
um
also okay so when I think of skills I
think the ideal wife would be very clean
right picks up after her self picks up
after the kids can make sure the home is
clean on top of that I think cooking
from scratch this is what I'm trying to
learn my mom's trying to teach me this
soon so I can be more wifey you know
what I mean
a cooking from scratch I think would be
great because a lot of times girls are
like I cook I cook well how many meals
have you cooked from scratch this week
this week right you know
can you bake a cake from scratch can you
bake a pie from scratch because y'all
don't have Thanksgiving here but we have
Thanksgiving are you coming to
Thanksgiving with the pie that you
bought from Tesco are you coming to
Thanksgiving with the pie you baked
yourself all right just describe an
American Mom I don't think European
women guests
you guys you guys have different
holidays here but it's the same thing
what are the kids gonna eat the kids
have to eat something are you feeding
them good food are you feeding them [__]
food well I wonder sorry but when you
said wifey I didn't know there was like
kids involved no but I do I know
yeah if I'm a man if I'm a man and I see
you I can just take you and so this is
what I would like think would be ideal
so a girl that works with kids all the
time so she already knows how to deal
with kids work with kids girl that cooks
all the time a guy can just say oh
perfect you already know how to do what
I need you to do right
um I also think a girl that really
supports her man and
you know wants the best for him
nurturing loyal loyalty is really
important yeah those are just Mom what
did I miss go off mom
I think a wife material is somebody
who's a nest Builder so a nest Builder
like you know I can I know how to cook I
know how to clean I know how to take
care of kids I'm going to defend my Nest
I'm gonna protect my Nest I'm gonna
build my Nest I'm gonna create family I
mean in my in our family if uh anybody
wants to like mess with any of the
Traditions like shit's gonna hit the fan
she'll yeah it isn't pretty so I think
but that's my role and so when I look at
wife material I that's that's what I
think uh makes that be true and how and
and that's what everyone loves about our
house as they come to our house we have
all these family traditions everyone
takes pictures with Santa every year no
matter how old you are yeah I make my
kids go to the mall and get pictures of
Santa Christmas like like all of them
wife material family is important to her
family is more important than her so if
she has to go out on a Saturday night or
spend time with her family she's gonna
pick her family every time but a lot of
times we have and just live their lives
for themselves
don't care about their family you
haven't even seen their family in three
years and then say I'm wife material
well you don't have any you don't even
spend time with the family you got all
right cool
all right let me say from a guy's
perspective of like wifey material yeah
uh first things first yeah
very family orientated yeah that's
absolutely 100 yeah and I think it's the
way you carry yourself like a lot of
girls out there are just constantly
advertising themselves with the way they
carry themselves the way they dress the
way they portray themself on social
media etc etc like if you want to look
like a lady of the night then obviously
guys are not going to perceive you as
wifey material I'm sorry that's just the
way it is like a lot of modern women try
to fight that oh I should be allowed to
wear what I want yeah wear what you want
and be single but that's it or be for
recreational use it's up to you
whichever one you want you can't say it
but um yeah the way you carry yourself
the way you um dress like are you a
party girl are you the type that you you
want to be the life and soul the party
you want to be at every event I'm sorry
that's not wifey material you're for
everybody you know what I'm saying and
that's it you know what I'm saying also
you know like you said being a man's
piece like a lot of times that that's
like a buzzword these days a lot of
girls are saying that don't even know
what that really means you get what I'm
saying like uh in my opinion a girl that
just tries her best not to bring you any
unnecessary headache a lot of girls find
that very very difficult press one in
the chat if you if you agree or hit the
super chat if you agree because I know a
lot of you guys are going through that
some of you guys never had a girlfriend
so you don't know what I'm talking about
but you will one day
you will one day RAV yeah and you know
just don't be annoying
um support what he's doing actually care
about him
you get what I'm saying like again
modern women these days it's all about
you it's all about your long laundry
list of the things that you want I want
I gotta make six figures I want a guy
that's six foot I want a guy with six
inches in the pants or better I want a
guy that is emotionally available and
emotional intelligence and he's smart
but he's got a little bit of hood to him
bro like you're you're looking for a
unicorn that don't exist number one and
a lot of times you don't think about
what you actually bring to the guy's
life because look you don't care
you know wifey material broth and that's
it okay then although a lot of a lot of
chicks these days are hyper
materialistic money money money money
money listen as a guy I understand that
a woman will want a guy that can protect
and provide for her financially
physically etc etc yeah but if you are
hyper materialistic and you are consumed
with consumption you're not wifey
material not in my opinion and most guys
who do have money and I know guys that
are actually doing well they can spot
these kind of women very very easily you
know what I'm saying again recreational
use those are the type of girls that you
see in the music videos or whatever oh I
was dating this rapper I was dating this
athlete blah blah blah blah blah you
didn't get the ring you didn't win
anything he was just he was just box use
this extra box that's it and wife
material I would think wants to save the
family money too because again like wife
material thinks about the family before
her so she's not thinking about what
money he could spend on her she's
thinking about what money can I save for
the family yeah what was he gonna say
Glenn
I see I see you you little I wanted to
say something
I'm personally not like a materialistic
person like that but as I said me I
think when I was thinking I wasn't
thinking I wasn't talking about you no
no no no no no no no okay I mean like
when I was saying it I wasn't talking in
terms of a family I think I was talking
more in terms of just me and him like I
wasn't thinking about
the extension because once you have a
family that's a whole novel Dynamic but
you don't think when you're like seeing
a guy you're not thinking of like
potentially what the family would look
like how that would work
it just depends if you want to have
children that I think that's that's the
biggest factor and that's what you need
to ask when you're trying to take
someone seriously whether they want kids
or not because but I think that time
like it's an interview process like
dating what's the purpose if yeah you're
not interviewing and so to me you know
you should be looking at him for is he
going to be the type of Provider to
protect and provide for your family and
for you is it you know are you ready to
fulfill the role of being the nest
Builder yeah me I'm not even thinking
like that I'm young
alone
when you said about the girls the way
the way they want to dress they can die
alone I was thinking Our Generation no
you said like uh the guys would say but
I would say no wifey material hold on
hold on hold on I said they're not wifey
material they're for everybody and
recreational use you gotta be careful
because like with me um if you say I
said something I didn't say I'm gonna
pull you up like you're gonna say well
material like the kind of girl the way
she dressed the way she showed herself
on Instagram whatever but I also think
our generation is not our dream to be
married with children that is the old
generation dreams the things are
changing quickly especially if you talk
about monogamy those days is something
that's not been easy without a divorce
especially in America you can tell about
the numbers in the UK or in Brazil so I
would say it's changing a lot the
conception of traditional family we had
in the past the things are changing a
lot the people are changing so the women
a lot of women doesn't want to get
married or have children oh that go on
do you think it's changing for good or
For Better or For Worse it depends it
depends on your point of view of course
it has to be worse it has to be worse
like I look at right now my mom is
terminally ill and so she had nine
children and her kids are taking taking
care of her it is a terrifying world to
think about all these single childless
women who are going to be warehoused and
you know killed by the system no one
take care of their grandparents the care
system are the one taking care of
everyone and the America is the same in
Brazil we step in to take care of the
family but not in this country
correcting if I'm wrong because they
need to change the law if you're living
with your grandparents you can Heritage
the house but once you're not there the
government can take over they had to
change the law because there is no much
children looking after their parents in
this country but in America is different
because they don't they don't have a
life
in my community people look after their
Elders this they do I don't think it's
uh I don't think it's
um country by country I think it's
family by family my mom had nine
children not all of them would take care
of her they just changed you know you
have a bunch of kids because you have a
bunch of kids somebody's going to so
these guys are just my insurance
policies
and that that leads me up to this the
next question
um uh okay cool how would you describe a
modern woman
how would you describe a modern woman
she kind of done it for you yeah and
like nowadays it's like
like how would you describe girls your
age like typically General
it should be easy
how old are you materialistic um 21 okay
materialistic
outside
active
what's the best word to use gone
honestly that
um
maintenance is a big thing as well nails
hair all of that makeup
I call that I'm even speaking by myself
right now
the truth will set you free not me I
could come over and do makeup on calm
but there's certain like in this
generation some people can't not do that
like they always I'm saying in terms of
like okay cool like you're describing
the Modern Woman yeah but okay let's
move it on to in terms of how they
interact with men in interim like we're
talking clubs like they see a guy with
nice car free ride term not really
thinking about the guy
there's that stuff there's oh there's
guys there there's the rich ones let's
go get drinks like I know some people
that will be saying like we can go
there's some girls that can go to
a club or ever with maybe one pound and
they could come out with a hundred so
you got like I'm saying I'm being very
rude about it like pretty people don't
even come out they won't even go to the
club with a pound they'll go empty empty
purse yeah lift home more money pretty
privilege is a real thing one of the one
of the guys in the friend zone will
drive them to the club yeah Bobby
go to the club with my friends can you
drop me there yeah yeah thinking he's
getting somewhere he ain't getting
nowhere but you're actually delivering
her to other man
you div oh yeah I mean so okay cool like
yeah I agree with you I agree with you
do you think that a little like women
your age are quite selfish
they can be
not from what you described kind of like
selfish materialistic I think the girl
too the girls are for the girls at the
moment like it's kind of girls are for
the girls girls are there and girls are
here like girl power in it therefore
we're deaf against each other at the
moment yeah yeah men are trash all this
but we'll still do what we have to do
for these men but how are the men
against the girls in your age group how
are they against them
[Music]
each other so nowadays well from my like
male friends and stuff they'll always
feel like they were being used
or who's being used the guy is being
used by a girl like they'll ask me to go
what do you think about this and I'll be
like I have to keep a buck with them
they're not interested like only because
I'm a girl I've seen it I've been around
girls so with my male friends I'll be
completely honest with you they're not
interested so if you continue that's on
you but you're not gonna get how the how
are the guys
um like against the girls then
in what way
I think they just don't like how we are
now like how girls are now like so but
but from what you've said
you've basically said that girls are
using guys and don't care about guys and
they don't even like them
and then the guys are basically not
liking that that kind of behavior so
it's not really the guys and girls are
against each other as the girls are like
basically bad behaved and the guys don't
like the bad behavior from what you've
described
yeah but yeah I feel like we're creating
a lot of villains so then
yeah there's just a lot of trashy guys a
lot of trashy girls and it's just back
off
and it's just yeah that's where you
there's not that many relationships but
where there are ones you know
Valentine's day you will see them being
exposed that they're talking to this
person this put it's just my generation
is just long black it's long no I hear
that all right cool what do you think
how would you describe a modern woman
you kind of did it already but yeah a
little recap she does what she wants she
doesn't care what people would say she
sleeps with the entire football team not
caring what people would say she move
abroad throughout the country if it's
necessary she's independent and a free
spirit
yeah would you like would you two um
describe yourselves as more than women
yes yeah
did you sleep well did you sleep with
the whole football team not yet but I
wish
listen she was stuff for a box leave
your movies Man live your movie
what about you dude would you describe
yourself as a modern woman
I mean you got you got the makeup you
got the nails yeah I feel like in terms
of the look and all that I do but I know
me as a person
I think like my mom what makes you what
makes you traditional like I'm just for
the hope that I like the whole idea of
being like a woman to a man like doing
what you have to do for a guy like I
like that idea of it like I do like
being having someone that's more
dominant having someone that can tell me
like don't do that like this is gonna
happen if you do that or like
and I feel like only a man can do that
for me like so you you like the idea of
a guy being an authority above you I'm
Your Leader your captain I'm not gonna
lie I do even though I'm a very dominant
female like I know I don't need a man
you go do you do you go to parties a lot
there you go anyway no not a lot a lot
that's that I'll be capping if I said a
lot a lot but I'll be going parties so I
have a can I ask you a question is your
mom from the UK yeah
um I was just wondering like
traditionally because I've just found
that a lot of people you said dude your
mom's mindset so when people say that a
lot of times they're not from the UK but
no um no so why why would you dress like
a modern woman if you feel like you're
traditional well it's not like mixed
marketing because like I'm a confusing
babe what I'm saying like so so if you
want to if you wanna if you want a
traditional guy and he's like let me
find some me a traditional wife oh I'm
confused with me right but I'm saying
like then you might not get the right
type of guy because if you if you
portray one thing he's gonna he's gonna
think that's what you are but right now
I don't personally feel like I'm looking
to be someone's wife okay I know I know
it sounds mad but I'm young back I want
to live my life obviously not sleeping
around the whole football team like
that's not just that's what my I do like
a couple
I do live but I do want to live like I
want to be able to say stories like when
I find my man just
what kind of stories man you're gonna
say stories no different stories
because I went to Dubai and I met this
guy then I went to Brazil I met this guy
that's not every sketch everything else
to be about you guys can I ask my mom I
want to ask her mother something real
quick mom um what stories do you like
telling us because you got you got
married at 21 right 21. when you you
your first kid at
we don't want to talk about that
18. yeah so she had her first get at 18
21 what stories do you like to talk
about
the ones of Our Lives I mean and that's
what I think the fallacy is is that you
have to have those stories alone and we
have seen all 50 states my kids have
been to
I don't know how many countries a lot
we've done we've absolutely lived a wild
ride and it wasn't you know there was
many many years we didn't have any money
so it wasn't about money it was about a
decision to live life and to live it
holy and fully and I just happened to
have babies strapped on my front and on
my back and usually in my belly so it
was why why do you think we have this
like mentality that like your life is
over when you have a family you can't
have these crazy stories once you have a
family because I think that our society
tells them that I think we have a
society that hates children truly and I
think that
um that I think women think that they
have to look bad after they have kids
and and I think they think that they
can't live their lives after they have
kids and I can tell you all of it's hard
like it's not easy but I've lived very
well I you know life is good and and I
have a herd of kids
truly I think I think a lot of it boils
down to like women kind of just want to
go and live some kind of music video or
something like some music video or some
or Instagram explore page they want to
do everything in every square of that
explore page bro and it's just
unrealistic bars
all you're going to do is rack up
mileage and Gather High bloody count
that's all you're going to be burnt out
but you can really you can do all of
those things if you get married and you
are working together toward those things
two people are better than one so you
can make but also financially talking in
different times like let's say if you
have a seven night children those days
you need a high income that I can tell
you that most of the time we had no high
income it was completely the opposite
but we work hard it it doesn't it's a
fallacy that it takes a lot of money to
raise kids it's a I don't believe it I
lived it I don't believe it I have a
question what's better two incomes or
one
[Laughter]
even
if there are no kids is two incomes
better is it what's better two incomes
or one so if you have a family of course
chewing comes is better than one for
sure that's
one would come for a family is a real
struggle
but if you're single of course yeah
three comes out always better than one
sorry that actually and I would yeah I
would tell you that I think that a
family income is better
not two incomes not one income it's a
family income so you're working together
so if it's either in a family business
or you know the wife supporting the
husband or however that all goes down
because I think that's you're going to
be more successful
together
100 awesome all right cool
um we're gonna check the likes on this
video because sometimes you lot cheat
treat me like I'm your side chick and
I'm definitely not that bro
so we're gonna make sure that you are on
job hitting the like button yeah because
this is a very interesting conversation
we've got over 500 people watching right
now and this is a good one all right
cool next question yeah uh what kind of
guys are usually successful with modern
women cool
yeah yeah I just wrote that one fresh
fresh so what kind of guys are
successful with girls or women like you
look
oh like me you're no mother so I think
I'll I'll know as well yeah she said
she's traditional I know
I know what she said I'm basic I'm
modern I know I'm
now accept your first answer I'm now
yeah yeah yeah yeah so so what kind of
okay in your mind what kind of guys are
usually successful with more than women
yeah both of you you know I believe like
I need to have a personality which most
of the people doesn't have they put in
material things guy think like oh I have
a defense car
or like I don't sleep with the car I
sleep with the person so for me it's
much more important what they can bring
to the table in a conversation or how he
treats people it's much more important
so for a mother woman doesn't matter his
income it must count is the company
quality his car his income doesn't
matter no because the modern woman can
work and it can have their own money buy
the things she wants okay is it is that
one is that all yeah that's all that's
all personality and what personality if
you have a personality
okay that's uh that's that's interesting
uh what do you think
sorry repeat the question what kind of
guys are usually successful with modern
women
um
the ones that like keep girls on their
toes when I say that I mean
well me personally I like adventurous
stack if someone just makes people alive
you've got my attention like how does a
guy make you feel alive how do you do
that
for the guys that I wanna for the only
other guys watching that wanna date
girls like you how does he make you feel
alive I wanna know this thing as well I
wanna know how do you how did your mind
work cheating
no
um so
me [__] I'm I'm an adventurous person I
like
Adventure when I say Adventure I don't
mean that Indiana Jones I'm telling you
all of that I love it like I swear tell
me we're going skydiving next week I'm
dear black that's I like that kind of
stuff so the guys how many times have
you been skydiving I haven't because the
guys I don't the guys no no wait let me
explain let me explain let me actually
explain because this will make sense
this will make sense because the guys
they're good at manipulating your brain
never done it I didn't say I love it I
said I would do it different there's a
there's a difference come on all right
so do I get a not doing it yeah there's
a difference I would do it I would do it
doesn't mean I've done it I would do it
how does a guy make you feel excited
come on
so they will tell I think I me
personally I get excited by the idea
which is
a bit messed up but they will do like
this fantasy thing and it'll make me
think oh yeah this is gonna happen this
is gonna happen and it will go left
oh so basically what's exciting is when
a guy sells you a dream yeah yeah it was
no that's how it was in the chaos yeah
the dream is the dream that you what
kind of dreams do you usually get sold
you're my girlfriend now look for kind
of dream no not that one I don't see us
going somewhere no that means
what makes you run I don't like that if
a guy feels odd like you're my real
girlfriend now not if I'm not ready no
that's me up still
so so
what are you looking for when you when
you I said advice just Adventure so
let's say the first date if you say just
find me in Heathrow I tell you later
would you go would you feel exciting
like
I want to know what these Adventures are
because you're just saying anything
yeah
what Adventures have you ever posted
that made you like a guy
a little bit more
I don't want to talk about them but
there's no Adventures there ain't no
Adventure there is I just choose not to
say them right we went to you went to a
restaurant I don't do restaurants see
you've already gone wrong because I
don't do restaurants
it's like a sexual thing when you say I
don't want to talk about it yeah did you
leave the country
I have once no she's talking about with
the guy that's what I'm saying like was
one of it's just a different it's just
there is stuff there is stuff but not
sexual why won't you tell us then was it
is oh is he a criminal
what no because like obviously if you
don't want to talk about it it's either
gonna be sexual
I like I like things that make me feel
like excited like adrenaline junkie I
love it there's just different stuff
you're making it sound more and more
sexual to me that means you guys got
dirty minds because I'm not even
thinking about that
I mean what would you not want to say on
a piece either illegal or sexual like
what just you know like
how do I explain it it doesn't have to
be that deep like you guys are thinking
like flying out all that I just like
things are exciting if that makes sense
oh roller coaster yeah I just yeah I
just like those kind of things so you
take you on a rollercoaster guys all you
got to do nope that's not modern women
yeah they want to be excited roller
coaster yeah but let's go most girls you
need that money
okay all right so okay cool like we've
been going around around in circles for
too long at the end of the day what
you're saying is that if I got to be
successful with a woman he has to be
excited that's what you're saying yeah
okay and you're saying that yes I have a
good personality personality
don't forget that I'm older than her
yeah I know you're definitely gonna have
different like mindsets because of age
obviously all right go on pool what are
you gonna say can I ask my mom a
question can I ask my mom mom what is
that okay okay Mom what do you think
um women should look for in a guy
assuming they want to get married yeah
yeah like if modern women are thinking I
need to be a wife tomorrow
they need to look at their um
I mean work ethic for sure hands down
big big item and will they be good
Fathers I mean assuming you want to have
kids I couldn't even imagine a world
without kids so
um I would say those two things and then
you know I think that there's a lot of
commonalities you know we're always
looking for something new and exciting
and different but the truth is is that
we often marry our dads we marry our our
moms whatever it is and so you know do
they emulate where you came from because
usually that's where you end up
not definitely so what do you think what
type of guys are usually successful with
modern women with modern women in
general oh gosh well I would say
cheaters for one yeah because I have
done she eaters for sure women love the
cheaters and Destiny came on here yep
talking about you Destiny and was like
oh Pearl modern women don't like getting
cheated on but why is it when I do these
Street interviews oh have you ever been
cheated on yes so we're all picking
cheaters right and then I'm like okay
did you leave or did you stay and they
all stayed they didn't leave okay and
then I'll be like when did you leave did
he cheat again is that what made you
leave no so I'm thinking two plus two
equals four modern women love cheaters
if you want her to stay keep on cheating
she'll she'll stay with you for a
lifetime she also cheat on him as well
she's modern she respect hers
I'm not saying she won't cheat back she
might but honestly I see I see the
opposite I see women cheat on simps more
on the guys that just like take whatever
and like we'll do whatever for her I I
see them cheating on them more and being
more loyal to the cheaters I'm not
saying I'm happy about this I'm not
saying this is the right way to go I'm
just saying what I see and maybe who
knows maybe I'm blind
maybe they maybe they date cheaters
because then it gives them the license
to cheat if they want to you would you
would think so no no
I I think I think women I think women
cheat more on the nice guys you would
you'd be surprised Mom it's true I agree
with you
yeah you're letting them know yeah you
agree with that yeah the nice guys
finish lost okay cool was he gonna say
um I feel like more time a lot of girls
feel like they can change them I'm that
girl that is not going to cheat on Black
even though you found out oh these
ghosts he's cheated on I'm gonna be that
one you know what yeah do you know what
yeah like I I think the cheating aspect
is a valid point but
that is not really the answer to the
question because what is it about the
Chia that makes him attractive and what
is it about the cheetah that makes the
woman stay that's what I'm really trying
to get at with the questions he's the
kind of guys
are successful what kind what is the
traits what's the what is the makeup of
that guy I can tell you it's because
evolutionary adaptation because all
right you know back in the olden days if
I was looking I was like who can I make
a child with and I see man a man a has a
harem of women I'm thinking all right
all those women picked him
so I should pick him too because they
picked him so he's got something worth
picking right on top of that it also
signals he can take care of the kids he
took care of all their kids so I mean he
could probably take care of all my kids
where guy a nobody's picking him why
isn't anyone picking him you know it's
like it's like what does nobody want him
can he not take care of the children
what's wrong so I'm not saying this is
great but it is an evolutionary
adaptation we can't even help though we
like cheaters goodbye
what does Poe's mom think about it what
kind of guys do you think are successful
with more than women elusive
elusive
um
okay because they feel like they can go
get any guy so the one that they can't
get is the one they want who
what does that what does that elusive
guy look like in your mind what's the
image
of that elusive black guy
tell dark and handsome hmm
and the first one is with pool is the
first one bro and he's got a thick
wallet fake one or he's at least got the
image of a thick wallet there you go
anyway so what do you what do you think
about what does what does he look like
the successful guy with women what with
modern women what does he look like
do you agree tall dark and handsome yeah
yeah
nice car I think it's if the guy is fun
he can be poor ugly fat whatever he
gonna get any girl he wants when he's
fun to make people last illusion breath
that's the illusion it's true
so basically you're saying any guy can
get any bruh where you reject guys think
about it
foreign
actually because it matters to you it's
about opportunity people just use day
chap those days I rather meet people in
real life and then when you consider
personality let's say it doesn't matter
how the look the guy has but if you make
me laugh if it's a funny guy so have you
slept so every guy that has made you
laugh have you had an entanglement with
every guy that's approached you and made
you laugh have you had an entanglement
whether you slept with them or had the
relationship or uh hookup or anything
like that every single time
no no exactly because there's some guys
you're gonna reject it's not feasible
for you to give everyone a chance you're
gonna have to have some kind of
preferences there
I don't think
yes but I I don't think
there's always a Bop no there is a butt
because I don't think it's just
physically you know I think it's the
package of the man what he can offer how
he treats people how he treats his
mother is really important for me as a
sample I always asking yeah but you're
not gonna know how he treats his mom
when you first meet him all that you've
got is that first impression that's all
you got in the first 10 seconds you got
an impression is he tall is he sure is
he fat does he look unhygienic because
he got bad breakfast he got Gamers he
whack yeah this is important that's what
I'm saying so when you say personality
and just be fun and as long as he's nice
to his mom I mean bro at the end of the
day you rejected guys that probably was
nice to their mom and funny and all of
that stuff and you rejected him because
he's too short or he's too fat or he
wasn't you know he wasn't the type of
guy that you find attractive